I just need to
mess with the Twitch setup.
Okay,
we should be set.
Let me open the reream page real quick
and I will switch the view over.
All right, so here's the deal. Uh, we
received a rather small little PR that I
wouldn't normally take much notice of,
but um, was it even a PR? No, I got an
email. That's why I noticed.
And it was just somebody saying that
they made our generalized advantage
kernels a little faster. Okay, cool. Oh,
I that's not probably worth my time, but
we'll see. Uh, let's just see if I Grock
pulls in that change if it does
anything. And I kind of figured like J
is not really a significant amount of
the training anyways.
But maybe there'll be something useful
there. And it was very useful. Um, even
compared to our now optimized path,
which was very odd. I want to follow
what you're doing. What video do I start
with?
We have articles on X, but other than
that, it's just the live stream pretty
much.
my uh my RL iceberg video is pretty nice
though for totally new people that's on
my main page.
Um okay, so yeah, this this update here
it made the J a bit faster, but the the
curve of the performance was kind of
interesting. So I figured like okay,
let's try this on Mr. Not really
expecting much because we tried this
quite significantly before. But
evidently I think we just messed
something up before.
So let me see something here.
Okay, it didn't mess with this, I
suppose.
What is this? Um,
Jeez, that's a really good perf, isn't
it?
38 mil.
But this is just our base. And then the
question is the degradation.
I suspect this will be one of those
improvements that we do need.
we're going to have to determinize this.
Yeah, this is just is this all just a
big fancy reduction?
Yeah, it's still a pretty big upgrade.
That's like several mil SPS.
Well, I wasn't going to be working on
core, but somebody sent an interesting
PR that I thought, okay, that's
interesting. Let me try this on uh
something else. It looks like we somehow
have a scan kernel that works on Mingru.
I don't understand how this happened
though because I like I tried this
several times and several other people
tried this several times.
This is so weird, man.
Let me see if I can figure this out.
It's a pretty complicated operation. I
mean, I can see
I think so. But it's very weird because
we've tried parallel scan several times
in the past and it has not helped.
And then this was immediately faster.
free CUDA. No, we we tried this on the
full CUDA version as well.
There's something that's different here.
Basically, what happened is somebody
submitted me some clever J kernel
that had a scan operation type thing in
it and um it is faster but
not that significant.
Oh actually this may be significant
here. H5
There's something weird here cuz the
times don't add up.
Yeah, that definitely there's something
wrong.
We'll see. Hopefully this is correct. I
mean, I guess I don't really mind either
way. If this is correct, then we get a
very nice speed upgrade. If this is not
correct, then we've like once again
confirmed that this is not doable and we
keep the current simpler design.
I will look at them. Thank you, convert.
I'm on um there's some weird
optimization that we might be able to do
here.
could be quite act actually could be
quite important
cuz this would essentially
would this fully let us use
I didn't think we had this amount of
overhead.
Somehow this is showing a big training
speed up.
It's suspicious, but if it's real, it
would be really good.
Interesting.
I'm still not entirely sure
how many launches is this.
Well, I want to check this thing just to
see if last minute we have a massive
perfin for free. That would be cool.
Um,
but aside from that,
pretty much just need to sweep the
environments and clean up some configs
and stuff.
Constellation little uh some
constellation tweaks. Got to clean up
the puffer mascot with that. But like
pretty simple stuff.
We're definitely on time.
I really should just see if I can
figure. Hang on. So, block.
Do we break up the horizon into chunks?
I tried this. I swear I did.
Right.
Man, I could swear I tried this exact
thing.
It's just uh So, you have blocks, right?
Yeah. Chunks
and then
Huh.
Okay. No, I don't. Oh, wait. That's the
backward. That's why I don't understand
that. Cool. No wonder. Uh, okay. So,
here are the chunks.
This has to be the ops for one chunk,
right?
And then a single combine maybe.
Oh, I can chat about um Inferno and
today
and Ko. I got kind of sides sniped here
because um somebody sent a PR that I
then applied to something else that has
it looks like a big perf boost.
Okay,
this is reasonable.
Yeah. Well, it's kind of weird in a
sense.
Tomorrow's good.
does the PR so they didn't PR this like
the thing is I got an email essentially
from somebody who'd written some Triton
kernels that they said uh are faster
than Puffer's J kernel above seek length
32 which like okay fair enough but we
don't really care because that's a tiny
amount of our compute but I figured I'd
just see if they did anything
interesting anyways and they have this
sort of interesting block scan
structure. Um, so I just had Grock like,
"Hey, see if this thing actually works
for our mining kernel," which is way,
way, way more important.
And it seems like it does.
Doing well. I'm doing pretty well.
I'm doing pretty well. I got some rest
since this weekend.
Run a couple of 10ks.
I'm doing pretty well.
Even if it's a 10% on this, that would
be pretty impressive.
And again, I think that um the policy
going forward uh from 50 is going to be
that we do not accept like complexity
and crap into puffer in order to improve
the performance of models that are below
100k parameters.
test if the math matches. Of course,
we're going to test that.
I mean, we'll just train the thing end
to end, right?
Even better.
Yeah, it's a modelbound training setup.
So quite possibly this could be
an end where it helps
>> We also hopefully it's not like reliant
on something that we can't do because of
determinism.
We will say
We got Volm slated for tomorrow.
Uh I do not find unit tests are better
frankly
and generally when we do unit tests we
treat them as throwaway.
They tend to lock the design far too
much for my liking.
It is easy to regress, but we also have
a whole bunch of ends.
There's sometimes where we can literally
just check that it's bitwise exact
versus the original. But then CUDA does
not give you um
it gives you limited determinism
guarantees.
So
Puffer is already basically as
deterministic as it's possible to get it
in as it's possible to make coup
or at least Kublas.
suppose yeah this could be a significant
bit of overhead even for um reasonably
sized models broad is the test
yeah I mean we test some stuff don't get
me wrong but I've always felt that
maintaining a big set of unit tests
locks you into a a specific
not even architecture but it basically
just freezes your code much more heavy
heavily than not having a bunch of unit
tests. And I've always found that the
best way to reduce the number of bugs in
the code is to always have it be as
compact as possible.
Two runs give exact same. Yeah, in
current puffer, you get bitwise
identical results out of two different
runs as long as they're on the same
version of CUDA. It's one of the things
we spend a long time um working to make
sure of now with this new kernel.
Probably not. And that's one of the
things that we'll fix. And hopefully the
sync mechanism is not where all the
savings come from.
We will see.
1 versus 1.2 too
4.7% to really
I would have expected better than that.
What is it all matt moles already by
that size?
How many T flops do you get? I mean,
that's going to be completely dependent
on model size and whatnot, right?
We typically measure time to solve
problem as well as peak throughput on a
useful configuration.
So one of the coolest numbers I can show
you is that we have up to 63 64 million
step per second training
um on a config that solves breakout in
about 900 milliseconds.
So, it's mostly like a matter of
the perf curve at different model sizes.
Like, you're obviously going to be
bandwidth bound
no matter what you do.
But there's still a good amount of room
for optimizations.
Yeah. Again though, it's a totally
different problem regime from larger
models. Like we're looking at we're
looking at between like 10,000 and 10
million parameter networks.
This may still be worth doing.
I think it is.
So what this would be long
long key.
I still need to understand what the hell
this thing is.
Best I can tell it's some sort of chunk
scan, but we did that before.
Yeah. No, we're just experimenting with
this thing for a little bit. Then I'm
going to try to understand what this
colonel is doing and see with a
combination of Grock and myself if we
can actually make it nice and compact.
Did they mess with this? It seems a
little slower than it used to be.
What are we linking here? Convert.
[clears throat]
doesn't have me logged in. Where did you
put it?
Is this just in the dev somewhere?
Oh, what? You link the points when you
hover them or when you click them.
bar church. Okay,
I can see a version of this
I think I probably would want to just
pipe the um like the magnitude of the
star or whatever way up instead of
drawing a circle. It just makes the
point like really obviously bright.
I think that'll be nicer with
constellation. But I think the thing
overall is nice.
Then here I think we can get it similar.
Yeah, I like the feature. I think I'll
change the implementation of it a little
though. And then the TNE plot I think we
need to replace anyways unless we want
to implement TNE and CUDA which sounds
awful.
We'll get a look at the at constellation
PR though for sure.
We have a hyperparameter sensitivity
visualization. Let's see. That's the one
on the bottom right.
Yeah, but the marginal distribution from
the GP is [ __ ] is the problem.
This is the thing that we found out
early is that the you can't just take
the predictions from the GP. You need to
actually run the experiments.
Yeah, it's better from 64.
Cheers.
Interesting. It's actually It is faster
here.
The break even point's a little sketchy.
Then if you go to like 256 or something,
25 mil,
28 mil,
still a meaningful jump.
It might just be that it's the reduction
to be fair.
So, it doesn't need to be bit for bit
identical with the non
uh the nonblock path, but it does need
to be identical from run to Um,
Okay. Yeah, if that works then it could
be pretty Good.
It's worth spending a little bit of time
on this in case it is a nice big uh perf
boost. We will see.
That would be pretty cool.
If it is, yay.
If not, no big deal. Worth investing a
little time. And then after this,
I think we kind of just start cleaning
up configs,
testing stuff locally, making sure
everything is sane.
Really, we'd like to get set up for um
the final the final sweeps for
constellation.
Oh, yeah. We also we can check convert
stuff to constellation. I also have to
decide if I want to change I do need to
change I have to decide what I want to
change for the bottom left panel.
Okay.
Uh, I suppose what we can do is in the
meantime
take back what I said about unit test.
This is pure bare metal.
Oh, puffer.
Yeah, it's actually pretty cool. Let me
show you something.
Are we in the right branch here? Yeah.
So,
this is our source.
Ignore half of these files. This is all
like me [ __ ] around with stuff.
Actually, wait. This is not at all the
right branch, is it?
Here we go. Way better. Okay, this is
our source. It's eight files,
10k lines total,
5,000 lines for all of our algo back
end. So, here's all our fancy network
and stuff. And then here is all of our
higherf infrastructure.
And then we have 1,600 lines devoted to
our visualization dashboard. This is
pure C and we can compile this for your
browser. We have our own in any loader
and then most of the remaining code here
is devoted to hyperparameter sweep. This
is again our own algorithm Gaussian
processes and cudac and then our CPU
evaluation back end. And that's pretty
much all the code in puffer.
Um our 4.0 release was 5,000 lines of
CUDA backend and then like several
thousand lines of Python glue. Our 50
release gets rid of all the Python and
instead it's going to be 10k lines to
NC.
I find this dramatically simpler to
reason about honestly than even like all
the PyTorch mess we had before. Much
much easier to understand Perf and
what's going on. And uh the results have
been very good. I mean, since we ditched
PyTorch, we took what was already the
highest performance RL library in
existence and we made it over 10 times
faster,
which is sort of ridiculous to think
out.
Sometimes I will let the model just like
screw around with a kernel or something
for a bit, but you'll see it's not going
to be like, "Okay, insta commit this
[ __ ] right?" Like, this would be,
"Okay, now I know it's correct. Now,
let's spend an hour cleaning it up if
we're actually going to keep this or
not. Um, let's not make a mess of our
nice code.
Like I spent several weeks getting it to
be this compact.
Okay, still 15 MPS on my local and this
only has a 3080 on it.
This is still fine.
So
I suppose that on the local
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We have a lot of
redundant parameters.
Yeah. So, this is what I was concerned
about that possibly
the reduction makes it slower.
I guess that would make sense, right? If
it is actually pretty straightforward to
have a good block um block scan kernel
but then at this scale like you can't
get nice return deterministic
reductions.
Cracked out. PO.
It's a little better than PO. It's
actually a little It's kind of
irritating. So, in our 3 update, we made
some pretty significant algorithmic
advancements.
Um,
but then in 40, because we came up with
a fundamentally better architecture,
two of those algorithmic advancements
turned out to not really matter anymore.
So it is now it's essentially it's
cracked out PO with Muon
and a uh a fundamentally different
architecture as well.
It also does have a pretty nice stable
async mode. It's kind of cracked out
async PO with Muan. I suppose at this
point
I guess whether you consider it the same
algorithm is kind of up to you. But I
will say this, if you just go try to
implement like the original PO paper but
as fast as possible, you will not get
remotely close to the same results as we
have here.
And then if you try to take some ideas
from Impala, you'll get even worse
results because that paper doesn't even
work. That was the finding from uh last
week
unfortunately
All right, this is um I was meaning to
do this for a while. This is just like a
strip dead keys thing.
One thing I can ask you all about while
I'm waiting for this. So this is our new
docs page. You see this is still local
build breakout puffer train puffer eval.
What do we think about that?
And in general what do we think about
the usage of the library here?
Make this larger.
Is this simple? Is this good? Is there
stuff we can improve with this?
I kind of want to make this as intuitive
as I possibly can for you all.
Change. It's just puffer eval. Yeah.
Like this.
Like we're no longer constrained to
argython
Technically, I don't even need the dash
dashes anymore.
We could omit the uh the dash dashes
or we could do single dash.
I'd actually we should probably look up
what is the canonical like we should
probably match more um like Unix CLI
tools
for full word is interest yeah but it's
not a like we don't even have the
abbreviations thing.
Single dash for dov, double for word.
Okay, so then we match already.
I don't really feel the need to give um
like a single letter headless or
whatever.
I think that this is fine like this
without having like single letter for
some stuff.
Do you really think it would be nice?
Like are people going to remember?
Cuz like keep in mind Puffer, we don't
ever make the promise that our uh our
commands and stuff are going to be
stable for a long time. Like we change
stuff around quite often just to
whatever the simplest thing is under the
current design.
Yeah, it's
And also you have the entire like args
like this, right?
in any of the sections can be set as a
command line flag arch.
Hello, Jess.
I got a really funny email with uh a
optimization for something that didn't
super matter and it looks like that
optimization is turning out to be pretty
major for Mingru.
At least this is no longer a disastrous
mess. This is just like two rather
complex kernels.
I'm pretty sure you can paralyze H as
well.
We do some optimizations. Oh yeah, we do
some optimizations though. Actually,
this might give us a way to do the C
kernel simpler as well.
Wait, why the hell didn't I think of
that? Am I a [ __ ]
Uh,
guys,
did I miss out on a really obvious major
optimization again?
Okay. So like
here [sighs]
no wait this one is
mining gate
grid size B * H
block size
Are we not already doing this? I thought
Wait,
Huh? I think we are. No,
because I don't have a loop over H.
to code physics? What do you mean to
code physics solvers?
I have no idea what you're saying. Hey
Tim, welcome.
We're looking at some colonels.
I the chat does not make sense to me at
the moment.
I think the thing I said didn't make
sense.
But then wait,
scan forward.
Maybe there maybe this version does it
wrong.
Okay, so let's see. Okay. So, we have a
number of chunks.
Yeah, I can't tell if it's doing it
already or not.
So, basically, I can let this screw
around, but we don't actually uh we
shouldn't expect anything from this.
If you have something that you think
works here, by all means,
um, it's embarrassingly parallel. It's
embarrassingly parallel along every
dimension except for T.
And then T can be paralyzed in blocks.
Okay, we don't expect anything from this
anyways.
That one has too many layers though.
Stream in D past.
Oh, wait. Start using Puffer.
I think we're set up to expire and end
just the stream and it did set up today
and started. Okay, very cool.
Yeah, it's it's very fast. You can do a
lot with the speed and I think 40 was a
40 was an update where we got a huge
amount of speed by going from torch to
cuda, but there were still a lot of
growing pains and stuff. I think 5 is
going to be the nice, clean, polished
version where it really feels CUDA C
native
and uh there's just not a bunch of
random janky stuff to deal with anymore.
I'm I like I'm genuinely not sure here.
I I need to spend more time looking at
this.
The good news is that this is a
relatively small code change
and we can test this pretty cleanly.
could get inverted, but otherwise I
think it's fine.
Not terrible either way.
Probably commit this
once I run a couple tests
and we can probably play with a few
things.
>> [clears throat]
>> When is 50 out?
Sometimes in the next few weeks,
I would say.
That any good? Actually, no. I actually
I hate that. Come to think of it.
What did it even delete?
I know what it is, dude.
I don't see how it's applicable.
working on publications.
No, I don't publish anymore. There's not
really a reason for me to.
I will work on some blog posts for this
release.
researcher. I graduated, man.
It says MIT PhD in my bio because I got
my PhD three years ago from there.
and get their
You only do that if you're a professor.
I have no desire to be a professor.
You think professors would be able to be
like sitting here writing code all day?
Virtually no professors actually get to
spend any significant amount of their
time um on code. They just get barged by
meetings and administrative duties and
stuff to the point that they have zero
time for independent work.
Why are we having if one?
Oh, okay. For testing. That's fine.
That's fine.
Well, basically the only way I can have
time for this, right, is by doing my own
thing.
That's why I did that's why I started
Puffer.
Can't run this with launch blocking.
That'll be a mess.
Well, I guess presumably this is also
just because the policy is quite big.
Yeah, let's try this with like hidden
size 256. Maybe
Definitely not so far, Meister.
I think it will long term.
No, we get clients.
We aren't like we're not just looking
for sponsors. There's no real money in
that.
I mean, the pitch is quite simple. We
build the highest performance, best
reinforcement learning tools by multiple
orders of magnitude. So if you're in
industry and you have an RL project, you
need a custom simulator, you need
integrations with our tools, who better
to hire us hire to do it than us.
We build ultra higherf dedicated
simulators.
We do custom research for problems that
are kind of just on the cusp of uh
current capabilities
and we also help prepare for
advancements that we know are going to
be in the next version or the version
after
Yeah, I mean that's kind of how I see
it. It's like what on earth could I
possibly be doing otherwise? I've kind
of in the last several years watched my
whole industry go to [ __ ] to the point
that like the vast majority of people
that I respected who were doing awesome
research are now working on something
utterly worthless because some LLM
company has scooped them up and paid
them a bunch of money.
And if you need the money, like, hey, no
shame on you. By all means.
But
I mean, I've not spent the last 15 years
of my life
working on this stuff in order to just
go do that. No thank you.
And the plan here is like with 50 we
have a really nice solid polished fast
version of
the current set of capabilities.
We need a few more benchmarks. We need
to really understand the remaining gaps
with what we can do.
We're set up very well to do that. Maybe
one last algorithmic push.
And I think at that point, we just start
building some really hard applied sims.
We start really trying to crank on uh
areas of science that are dependent on
simulation for advancement
using
our tools.
I mean, Stevie, I'm not unmotivated by
money, right? Like, there is a business
side to this as well, and that's
important because it also lets me hire
more people that I know are really good,
push the research forward.
Plus, it's good to have some cash in the
bank,
but I mean, not at the price of not
being able to build the stuff that I
need I know needs to exist.
That is also true, Meister. That is also
very, very true. It's often used as an
excuse.
And the way that you can see that is
that they don't quit after two years.
Do LM get the money?
Yeah, but that would have been
miserable.
I think I'd honestly rather hang out
with your average like bloke in a rural
bar in Alabama
than I would with like your average SF
tech bro.
Oh, this is also just way more
enjoyable.
Well, not this, not the staring at
stupid Grock window portion.
Obviously, there going to be portions of
building a thing that are just kind of
boring and annoying, but
the overall process for There.
Mhm.
Okay, this is much better. This is
actually
Wait,
why is it 10%.
10% would still be good. Don't get me
wrong.
Mr.
So this architecture is a product of our
own research. It's completely custom.
It is a combination of mining which is a
simple linear recurrence
and highway connections
which is well from a very old set of
papers and something that I used in my
first ever published paper.
The key here is that highway connections
prevent you from needing layerorm and
layerorm is very very slow and unwieldy
especially for small models.
We actually, if you check my uh my
Twitter,
J Suarez, there's an an article on the
architecture.
How much faster is 5o versus 40? So far,
the peak speed increase is over 3x.
I think a lot of problems are going to
get like a 1.5 to 2x boost
with Async especially.
This is supposed to be a smaller update
than 40 and it is, but it's still good.
We'll call this a roughly 10% on average
improvement.
I think this is a roughly 10% on
average.
Don't listen to music while I work.
Well, I have the chat here and then I
also have one,
two,
I have plenty of distractions as is.
Believe me,
I'll usually close at least one of those
if I'm doing something that's uh
much more attentive.
the bottom l.
I mean, we could do it if Riot's
interested in that.
Be a big project, but we could do it.
Uh, likely not on A5090,
but with enough simulation engineering,
likely we could do it on 85090s.
What? Strong weights. I have lots of
articles on X. It's J Suarez. Just my
last name. Jay, my last name on X. the
articles tab.
So, this actually is not a scan really.
It's parallel loads.
Wait having an approximate training
fine-tuning on an exact
we do but the most convincing example
that I have of that is not something I
can share publicly.
It takes a bit of work I will say. Um
but yes that does work.
Trying to think if we have any good
examples. I mean you can look at the
drone env. I suppose
the domain randomization and such in
there is quite nice and you can actually
run that on a real drone. Uh Finn has
some demos.
It's over 10k again. We'll have to cut a
few things, but no biggie.
I saw
the demo earlier.
Rich Sutton's
I've been pretty bearish actually on a
lot of uh obviously the guy's a legend.
I've been pretty bearish on some of the
ideas he's had lately. Okay.
It's kind of weird for him to like
split with uh with Carmarmac as well.
Agenda for today.
Well, we just merged
a pretty nice
improvement.
how many steps do you usually per sweep
and all so typically we start with like
a reasonably sane config
that does something and like the amount
of steps that is run, the model size,
the hypers, all of that is determined
automatically by protein.
The algorithm is very good. It
essentially it attempts to get the
highest performance for every fixed
amount of compute you could spend. So
it'll see what's the best run I can get
in 10 seconds and 20 seconds and 30
seconds.
And it also biases such that
it won't just keep running really long
experiments if there's not a benefit to
them.
So an experiment actually has to be
better uh that is longer before it'll go
more than that. What did I merge? I got
a funny email with a potential
improvement to one of our kernels which
did work but did not end up really
mattering. It was like a less than 1%
performance improvement, but then we
were able to use the same technique on
something that was more important and we
were able to get like 10%.
Not on everything, mind you, but on a
lot of our configs it'll be around 10%
and some of them it'll be much more than
that.
Okay. Um,
let's go check what Kinvert did in this
PR.
We'll see if he listened because I did
warn him that we're going to be very
protective of Constellation.
Okay,
that looks like a reasonably small
delta.
Yeah, I just pushed that.
I got to also tell the guy via email
that the thing worked.
What do we put on the bottom left is
going to be the question.
interesting results might be next
research direction. Glad to hear that.
If you uh find anything that you think
would be useful for Puffer as a whole,
let let us know. or if you have any cool
environments.
Always looking for new benchmarks.
So this bottom left part you this bottom
left plot actually let's pull it up on
the website so people get a better idea
cuz that that looks way better.
So we had this nice tene right.
I do think something with hyperparameter
importance.
going new task few config keys
related to risk. Yeah,
if you've seen Finn's demo, uh
[laughter]
he does actually have some puffer
policies on a real drone.
It's pretty cool.
I'm going to use the restroom real
quick. Or actually, no. I'm just going
to walk around and get myself a drink, I
think, real quick. I I have an idea in
the meantime. Let's Let's try something.
can't use protein.
Yes, I did mention that you don't uh one
thing that we found very early is you do
not want to trust the Gaussian process
directly. You only trust it to select
the experiments and then you you
interpret the experiments directly. You
don't interpret what the Gaussian
process says about the experiments.
Uh yes, we could we could do a loading
feature for it to be fair. Yes, that is
a thing. Um
that may be useful. The main reason I
haven't done that is for fear of
contaminating experiments.
like if something gets changed in the
middle.
I definitely agree that could be very
useful though.
We still don't really have a good way of
doing that across M though,
which would be the most useful.
But yeah, making it so that we start
getting some reasonable suggestions
immediately instead of after a 100 runs,
that would be pretty pretty damn good.
There's probably a way to do it.
Use the restroom and grab a drink real
quick. We'll fish for a couple ideas for
constellation
and then uh we have some environments to
fix up. We've got some sweeps to set up.
Few different things to do. I'll be
right back.
I mean, the biggest thing would be is if
you could just like take all the ends,
right, and somehow get a starting point
for your sweeps out of that.
That would be really big. I just don't
see any way to do it.
I don't want to creep too much into this
update to be fair.
We have the puffer mascot changes. No
big deal.
We'll figure that out.
Like other than this, it's just the
sweeps.
There are lots of things that we still
would like to have um that aren't fully
there yet,
but
I think this is okay at the moment.
Oh, if we don't find anything,
one thing that we totally could do that
I am fine doing is we could just punt on
the t-ne
and we could just ship constellation
with
um
with like pre-baked tiss knee
or whatever set of baselines we release.
The new puffer is not great yet, Arch.
We're having problems with it.
It's very frustrating to me actually
with the amount of money that we spent
on modeling.
It is like working with artists is kind
of like working with programmers in that
like some of them are just awesome,
but unless you really know your stuff as
an artist, you don't have a way to tell
who is actually good
even based on their portfolio, believe
it or not.
Um,
and the bad ones are just like
the bad ones are just awful.
We've had a few very, very good ones
though that we've worked with over time.
Um, but not in the area that we needed
for This
I'm trying to come up with some other
ideas for uh for constellation.
we could use it to plot all our ends in
difficulty.
the number of like dumb things that you
get like back though.
I mean it's like
it it would be stuff like oh this puffer
is great but it's missing a fin. Oh,
I've added the fin back. Please check on
this. Cool. Now it's crosseyed for some
reason. Why is it crosseyed? Okay. Hey,
here I fixed that. But now it's missing
the fin again. Oh, okay. Now it's not
missing the fin and it's not crosseyed.
Okay. But like this thing here that I
asked before is still not like h man.
Compute versus difficulty. Yeah. So I
was thinking of that, but then the
problem with compute versus difficulty
is that it would have we could do it,
but it would require us to set a
threshold on Perf
and it would require us to really think
about how we scale Perf, right?
I don't think if there's anything else.
I guess there are a few small things I
want to have done.
Those
What manual work is left on release? I
guess it's mostly just writing the blog
post and then making sure results and
stuff are good, as well as just having
used it for a little bit more time, like
using the final version for a while to
make sure that it's good.
See, but the problem with number of
flops, right, is like for these very
small models,
there's a pretty big difference. Um,
well, I guess we could act. Could we do
that? Let me think. Maybe there is a way
to control that.
We could just do some basic version of
this, right? like parameters time steps
approx equal flops.
That's actually really easy to just add
to constellation as an axis though,
isn't it?
I think it would be closer to params
times obs.
It should be proportional to the net
size like linearly
thing. I think it just takes forever.
Now, this is on medium as well. I do
wonder if they made it if they nerfed
the uh the speed.
Takes a second to load because it's a
big policy.
I have a feeling this has come up with
something dumb.
The other thing we could do is we could
make the uh constellation panel tabable.
I think it's it looks so much cooler
like this.
Yeah, I could do full view of each.
That's weird.
I don't know why it does that. That's
weird.
Spearman heat map. Yeah,
we'll see if there's anything usable.
I'm kind of just fishing for ideas.
Purto fronts. Of course you are.
This entire thing is the parrito front.
Like these are the paro points.
I think we're pretty generous at the
moment that we allow it to be Purto in
steps or in uptime,
which is why you get both.
so that you can plot either way.
The whole algorithm like all of protein
is built around optimizing the paro
front. That's why it's good.
I don't know either of those benchmarks,
my guy. I don't do LLM
Okay, so it just came up with a whole
bunch of ideas.
What do I do?
We do RL on it for everything but LLMs.
We have the highest performance
RL library out there. We're able to hit
over 50 million steps per second on a
single GPU. We do incredibly high
performance simulation.
We have architecture research
co-designed for this as well. We have
tons of demos on puffer.ai,
drones, driving, lots of games, other
scientific applications as well.
Superhuman policies with tiny policies
you can train on one GPU or on one
machine.
How big is the team? fulltime Spencer
and I open source.
Uh Finn's with us for the summer as an
intern and other than that it's just the
open source community.
It's a pretty compact library,
but it is genuinely a thousand times
faster than other stuff out there.
Why? Because this is my startup.
Upperai is a startup.
Her stuff's open source.
Biggest env you can in terms of agents.
Uh the number of agents per env is not
really a limitation at all.
Like neural MMO has a thousand. You
could set up a snake EN with 4,000 very
easily if you wanted to.
I would suppose that the practical
limitation is if you go above eight or
16,000
in one environment, you start to have
obnoxiously big batch sizes,
but that's pretty much it.
Where do you see revenue coming? It's
right on our homepage.
We offer services professionally.
We build ultra high performance
environments for companies. We do
integrations with our tech. We do
contracted R&D.
Generally, the idea is we build the best
tools in the space and you're free to
use them. But if you'd like to get the
most out of RL, why not hire the people
that built them?
And we do have revenue. Puffer is
profitable already.
What's the best way to get AI
researchers
space and struggling to find good day?
Well, it's very difficult to do that in
general.
because there's a massive bidding war
as well as many of the best ones have
decided screw it, we're doing our own
thing Now
yeah, in my case it's like the thing
that I'm doing here. This has to exist.
If you look at progress over the last
few years in reinforcement learning like
non LLMRL,
there's basically been zero progress
whatsoever uh on algo space, on
infrastructure, on tools, on everything.
In fact, I'd argue there's been negative
progress in many areas.
But if you look at Puffer, this exists,
it's like less than 10,000 lines of
code. And it's over a thousand times
faster than the standard libraries with
tons of environments that are way more
complex and interesting than anything
that is being used in academic research
or in industry right now.
Um, so like of course I'm just going to
keep doing this
because I think it's important.
Yeah. Yeah, it did finish but I have to
actually figure out Okay, this is just
me fishing for I'm basically just
fishing for ideas here.
Is this just like a straight
correlation?
Oh, yeah, sure.
Here, I'll make these larger.
We're basically we're trying to figure
out what we want to put on the uh the
third plot of constellation because we
have to replace it with something.
way to connect. Jwar is at puffer at
puffer.ai for professional inquiries.
You're not going to be able to hire me
directly for like a different effort.
The business does um if you need a
custom SIM though or something, you can
hire Puffer.
We have a little bit of availability at
the moment.
Our next big release is coming out in
the next few weeks as well.
Yeah, I don't think that this is
interesting, right? This is just saying
that like
I guess there's this replay ratio
correlation, but this is so noisy
and this is noisy on um a lot of data as
well. Like this is not good.
Hyper versus long run score. Again, this
is like the same thing.
I think this is literally the same
thing.
Oh, here we go.
Hyper with parto proximity.
No
barcode. What?
Some correlation.
I mean, the thing is there's it's like
clearly too noisy to be anything
pulled across games.
Well, I mean, just looking at this, this
is nothing.
This looks cool, but does this tell you
anything?
I think this just looks cool.
This is like the type of thing where
maybe because this is not super noisy.
chat miss. Did I miss something?
Did I miss a message or did uh did it
not show up?
You'll not be Oh, my bad. You'll not be
interested in RLMs.
massive.
Yeah, but there's plenty of people doing
that stuff already. There's zero people
doing what I do. So, basically, if I do
not build this, this tech will not
exist.
And I think it's very I think that the
stuff I'm building at the moment will be
equally as important as LLM's.
Whether it makes the same amount of
money as LLM is another story, I think
it'll make plenty.
But regardless, I think it will be
equally as important.
Okay. This something like this is a
Maybe.
Maybe
knight
infra.
Yeah, but that's what we fixed here.
Right now we just have really good
infra.
Long run score percent versus hyper
quintile
pulled across games.
seven.
What's this tell you?
What's this tell you that our like
existing plot doesn't tell you?
I mean, there's not like a global like
dial MIT, PhD registry or something.
It's kind of just a bunch of people out
there in the world, you know?
I am actually thinking about doing like
some flop scaling thing.
I get tons of emails from people like
trying to hire me for just random stuff.
A lot of like random finance stuff as
well.
just like
meh.
benchmark that puffers. We have lots of
benchmarks.
The problem is we keep solving all of
them too fast.
more business guy. See,
aren't you monetizing it? It's not our
business model
cuz the benchmarks out there for
typically for LLM.
Like our plans are pretty simple. Like
we crack really fast, stable, consistent
RL
And then we go use it to solve a bunch
of hard problems that matter and mostly
in hard science
Yeah. But everybody's building
benchmarks for the Frontier Labs
already. Like there's nothing unique
about what we do that is specific to
like would be great for Frontier Labs
specifically. Like yes, I could easily
build a ton of benchmarks that would be
useful to them, but they wouldn't
advance the core thing that we're doing.
So I mean on the business side, then
surely you can appreciate the value of
not getting distracted by things that
are not your core your core company,
right?
There's always going to be some shiny
thing that everybody's doing that seems
to have lots of money around it.
But that's not what we do.
Plans on extending ALGO
PO. We have a few plans. Uh but frankly,
Resza, I've gone through all of the
offpaul lit for the most part. Uh the
biggest section of the world modeling
lit. Um several other random algorithmic
areas. And I've probably at this point
gone through a half dozen of the most
promising possible areas and tried stuff
out on Puffer.
The majority of the literature is wrong.
Like just straight wrong. Their
baselines are super easy. So it looks
like their algorithm does something, but
then you put it on top of a good
baseline and does nothing or worse than
nothing.
So our agents that we develop
are let me calculate
million
billion
somewhere between I guess if we're going
to talk usable agents
um we're probably somewhere between
10,000
and
a million times faster than the agents
that are out there.
So, it's a completely different problem
regime.
It seems like basically impossible that
you're ever going to be able to use LLMs
to solve the stuff that we solve
efficiently.
You can light money on fire to force it,
I guess, but it's going to always be
like at least 10,000x the cost
risk sensitive RLET.
I actually know one guy in constrained
RL who's very good.
Um
I think he's in his like second or third
year PhD now.
It's pretty tough in general though. Um
I think a lot of the lit that's focused
about exploring safely
is not as applicable because you're
always just going to be training in sim
anyways.
Okay guys, I do want to actually solve
this today. Um,
what about some sort of Yeah, some sort
of compute visualization. I think
we could actually somebody asked about
MFU before.
is that not
that might be a good addition to the top
right chart.
Yeah, it's again the type of stuff we do
is very different. Let me give you an
example.
These cars here are controlled by a
self-driving model that's trained in
simulation using Puffer Lib. This is the
highest performance open-source
self-driving simulator that is
available.
You literally only need a 1 million
parameter network to be able to train a
good self-driving policy. And now this
simulator, as well as Puffer as a whole,
is being used by multiple different
self-driving companies,
including deploying on the road.
No form of an LLM ever makes sense for
this.
algo change. Uh Jess, it's it's not an
algo change. It's just a um an optimized
kernel for longer sequences for the
mining grew scan. It's just opt it's
just paralyzing the loads. It actually
it turned out to look very fancy, but
it's pretty simple. It's like a 100 line
edition and it's plus 10 20 10 to 20%
depending on the sequence length and
stuff.
It's pretty decent.
MMO train. Nope. One policy
independently controlled separate
policy.
I did. I replied on that info, please.
Agent orchestra. Like that's again I I
meant that that's an entirely different
space because that those are all
language agents.
It's not what we build.
Like we have multitask training and
stuff, but it's a very different space.
Like our version of multitask training
would be something like this. This is a
racing policy for a drone. If I just hit
um if I hit tab here. Oops, wrong one.
Hang on.
So yeah, this is a this is a racing
policy.
If I hit tab here
formation,
different formation. This is the same
neural net, the same policy just given
different instructions essentially.
Oh yeah,
that end of his um work by our intern.
It's also tiny, you know, far less than
a million parameters.
You can run it on a potato.
Different policies for different agents.
M's where you need to train. Hang on.
Hang on. I don't agree with the premise.
Why do you need to train different
policies?
agents for optimality?
It's not that it's outside of the scope
of puffer. I reject the premise.
sound like my uni professor.
I speak so incredibly casually and
without care compared to how I used to
talk.
This is considered me getting sloppy on
uh on my comms as I've just gone super
deep into the tech side in the last few
years.
I still try to think very clearly about
all the problems that I'm working on,
though. That I've probably gotten better
at.
I tend to have a very clear picture of
what I'm doing and why.
I'm thinking something about the PF of
puffer as evaluated on all these ends
would be nice, right?
in touch with any potential clients. I
mean, we're m mostly looking at large
companies that have substantial
reinforcement learning projects
that they would either like us to do for
them or revamp for them or what have
you.
and specifically non LLM RL, right?
We're really not looking to expand into
um LM stuff.
No, I don't think so. There are still
lots of companies that have non LLMRL
projects.
The typical message when I like when I
talk to companies, it's like, "Yeah, we
tried it. It was hard and we couldn't
figure out how to do it." And then I
tell them, "Well, we're doing it and our
stuff runs 10,000 times faster than
yours did. And here's the proof. So, uh,
that gives us quite a bit of a leg up."
And then they say, "Oh, okay. Well,
let's try a small project to see how
this works.
and then we've like solved their problem
in two weeks. And that's typically how
we get started.
I'm trying to think exactly the plot
that I want.
I guess just model size. Honestly, what
if it's just model size versus SPS?
That's interesting. Potentially.
Nope.
You be okay seeing our research and
giving us review.
I mean with stuff in my domain. Yeah. I
we all we have services.
Um,
not like general ML or general AI review
though
X message. Uh, let me check the Discord.
Hang on.
Gen
drone M has variable setting for the
mass and it differs across drones. So in
constrained RL
if control movements then heavier drones
should move less distance.
Yeah, I mean, we intentionally randomize
to make our agents more robust. It's not
harder, it's actually easier.
Um, the way to look at it, it's it's
kind of a form of CIS ID in a sense
where like whatever shape and mass and
whatever the drone has, it's going to
fly around a little bit and it kind of
just takes its first few shaky steps and
then says, "Ah, okay, this is how the
physics roughly work." And it flies fine
from there.
It's a pretty cool approach.
fine-tuning open weight models.
Yeah, again that's outside of my domain,
man.
You don't need like a giga specialist in
RL for that.
That's pretty generic work.
Do you know any real world industrial
applications use for mission control?
Uh, I don't, but it will definitely be
used there.
I think the main problem is just RL
being janky and not working if you try
to do stuff with SP3 or whatever.
IPO didn't solve was violation of budget
use what's that mean
what would not be generic work sure so
the general services that we offer uh
the services that we offer that tend to
be like the main thing that companies
hire us for we build ultra high
performance simulations for specific
specific tasks and problems. We've done
stuff in defense, animation, games,
finance, commerce, and we build sims
fast and in a way that combines well
with RL. We have helped integrate our RL
stack on existing environments as well.
And then we've also done contracted R&D
where a problem is well suited to RL but
it needs something that's just sort of
slightly outside of the normal set of
applications and uh has needed us to
develop some slightly varying techniques
to account for.
Those are the types of things we
typically do.
We could try to get like MFU
by param count.
Yeah, thanks for dropping by.
Let's say you have a budget limit for
the entire team.
What do you mean you have a budget limit
for the entire team?
Wait, were you trying to do that across
all drones?
Cuz you can definitely do that for a
single drone. If you're trying to do it
across the entire like all the drones,
then yeah, you've created like a
massively difficult coordination
problem.
You would just like try to have them
optimize their individual budget.
Okay. Right. But like you'd need to give
me a practical instantiation of that,
right?
Cuz if you just want them to like go
through the rings while minimizing fuel
or minimizing like redundant movement or
something, like the solution is going to
be pretty much the same if you do it
individually or if you do it jointly,
but it's going to be dramatically harder
to learn jointly.
So if you have a joint problem, then
there needs to be a meaningful joint
solution.
And then specifically if you don't if
you are just using drone as a proxy to
study this problem I would make an end
that way better models like the specific
thing that you care about because you
have the whole control learning thing in
the mix with drone.
Like here's a very very simple
environment by the way that shows like
some level of multi-agent awareness.
I'll give you a really simple example.
This is from our new demo like our new
uh like template environment.
So there are multiple puffers.
There are multiple targets of each
color. the targets go on cool down when
you hit them. So you have to spread out
and hit different targets
of your color. So if you just if all the
agents just go to the nearest one and
they ignore what the other agents are
doing, they uh they will undersaturate
and they'll have a bunch of them off
cool down.
This did not require any custom
algorithm work. It just required a
slightly custom encoder because the
agent could not see correctly.
right, let me use the restroom real
quick.
I have a maze.
Wait.
probably if you set it up correctly.
Yeah,
only special thing
safe hatching that cost one. Oh, okay.
That's interesting.
I mean, I could give you some advice on
how to formulate that. Were you the one
that submitted all the ends recently or
no? Is this you?
Oh, if this is you, then I can probably
help.
Yeah. So, I guess why is this
my first question to you is why is this
a specifically a multi-agent problem,
right?
If you give me some like simple
formulation of this that I can read
through, I will I can sanity check it
for you.
Yeah, replay ratio one is going to be
the issue, right?
that's probability of what constraint is
greater than a constant.
So you violate the constraint
of some fixed budget less than alpha% of
the time.
He is total team cost.
Okay. But is the
is it a team problem is the question
that I have, right?
Because if you're going to ascribe a
joint multi- aent objective over
something that's clearly the agents
don't interact in any meaningful way.
You see the issue
that's like basically saying hey if I
put you in a box somewhere and then
there are nine other people in boxes
otherwhere that are solving your same
problem.
like how do you optimize stuff such that
they don't break the constraint?
It's sort of a screwy setup.
There's probably some optimal joint
thing you can write down for simple
cases,
but that's fundamentally like not a
learning problem.
Like if you can't observe your teammates
spending budget right as they're
spending it, then what are you supposed
to do?
So if you want this to be a joint
problem, then it has to be a meaningful
joint problem.
It can't just be something where you can
write down an oracle solution that's not
learnable within the problem itself by
an agent or by a person or by anything,
right?
You can see that and learn. Okay.
So, yeah, I have to see a version of
that to sanity check. Either if it's
going to be an NFPR or like what,
however you want to do it.
I don't know if you have some simple
version of this that I can just like
check the PR or something on later this
week
Okay, let me take a quick look at this
and then I'm going to chat with Spencer,
I think.
Which which end does this correspond to?
Is this the maze end or which one is it?
the maze.
Okay, so hang on.
I How does this map to anything? Let me
see.
How does this work?
Where did your MS just go? There they
are.
Well, this is interesting.
Wait, are these walls?
it cost like is it like it costs budget
to walk on the dark squares and it
doesn't cost budget to walk on the gray
squares?
Is that it?
Or is it only darkest walkable?
Wait. So what's hard about this? This is
like a simple maze.
Oh, okay. Yeah. The issue here is cuz I
get it. So, the issue here is that it's
stepping simultaneously,
right?
So, all the agents are stepping
simultaneously.
So unless the budget is quite large by
comparison,
you're going to like jump way over the
budget in one step, I would presume.
But then that's a formulation problem,
right? of having it be simultaneous.
Okay, this is janky as a sequential
problem. I will admit um it's janky to
model this as a sequential problem.
Is it it is realistic?
Not particularly because you have a
really really big chunk of dis like time
discretized, right?
This is like a five or 10step problem
that you like each chunk of time is big
and that also means that you can't like
really wait for the other agents to see
what they're doing.
So yeah, basically the way that I would
do something like this is I'd probably
just have each env be one of these and
that like every step it cycles through
like one, two, three, four. So maybe
each end has four of these scenarios set
up and but on each step you only get to
see and act in one of them. And then
there would have to be an action that
lets you just pass your turn with no
penalty
at least like at the start. So you'd
have to at the start be able to see all
the four scenarios maybe. So 1 2 3 4 you
see all four scenarios
and then you can start start taking
steps
to try to solve optimally without
allocating budget and that'll instant
solve. Yeah, that will just insta solve.
Budget is updated. Yeah, but even though
the budget is updated per agent, it's
still simultaneous.
And they can't see each other's problem
either, right?
Like presumably they can't see each
other's problem or can they?
Well, yeah, then of course that's not
solvable.
I mean, you've given them an impossible
problem.
I assume that the planning algorithm
uses global information
like they can do something but you can't
optimally you cannot optimally solve
that. I would be shocked if you could
using local information.
Nope. The planning algorithm doesn't use
global information and it solves
optimally. really
how you don't know what you don't know
the difficulty of your problem relative
to the other agents.
The goal here is that like the agents
that have to spend the least cost to get
the most reward should do that and then
the agents that would have to spend a
lot of the budget in order to get um a
reasonable amount of score should not.
You need information from the other
agents to do that
implicitly get that input from the
budget?
Well, wait. If the budget is computed
based on an oracle solve, then I guess,
but that's just leaking information that
they shouldn't have, then it should just
be like some fixed budget.
Even if you perfectly know the
distribution of maps, you don't know
what sample the other agents got.
Like the correct thing would be that
like whoever has the easiest map, right,
to get the most reward should just do
all of their actions
accumulation cost.
You still need to be able to see the
other ends.
Yeah, I'm confident I could set this up
in a way that would work pretty simply.
Um 16 M's might be kind of hard because
that's a lot of coordination. I'd
probably anneal it. So I'd do like a
differing number of M's.
I don't think that gives you the
information fully.
Yeah, I think I've got to chat with
Spencer now. But um
I think you can definitely set up a
version of this that makes sense and
that you will install with puffer
skills to 1,000 agents on this problem.
1,00 agents might actually be easier.
the hardest is probably like some number
in the middle. Cuz
with a thousand then the distribution's
consistent.
Okay. I can take some time at some point
to try to like fiddle with this N.
It's just an N problem.
I think it's a formulation problem.
All right, I'm going to end the stream
and go chat with uh with Spencer. I
think I'll probably be streaming some
tomorrow to be determined. Um
kind of a slow day. We fixed one thing
though. I definitely have some more
stuff to do pre-release, but it's pretty
basic. I just have to sort of set up
some experiments and stuff. Um, anyways,
thank you all for tuning in. If you're
new around here, Star Puffer on GitHub.
It really helps us out a lot and it's
free. I will see you around.